I'm making money here my friend Jim how
you doing Jenna hey we saw something
interesting wanted to share with you
we're at the hospital and real good how
what do you think Jim
yes nourishment let's see what they have
Eddie nourishment okay let's see well
you see free charging station for
cellphones if you got a sick Oh in here
or we have a vending machine
oh let's see what kind of nourishment
they have in the vending machine
let me see we have lays kettle cooked
potato chips we have ruffles someone
like that would be like vegetables no
she said no not exactly
we've got nibblers we've got Famous Amos
chocolate chip cookies oh that's that's
really delicious nourishment Twix
Snickers Oreos Eminem's planners roasted
and salted peanuts not Organic peanuts
though peanuts have taken the grand
prize for the most pesticides saturated
food grown in America according to one
study done by the FDA awhile back
peanuts were the most pesticide
contaminated food peanuts and food
supply yes and planners are not organic
peanuts and we have all let's see we
have coke of course diet coke diet coke
with three addictive and neurotoxic
ingredients aspartame and also MSG
listed as natural flavors and let's not
take for granted the addictive qualities
of caffeine in there and then we hello
we have more varieties of coke we have
cherry coke and we have sprite and we
have Fanta and a brand of soft drink
I've never seen before it's Hughes oh
well so this is what the hospital
considers
nourishment I think that they need some
very comprehensive and urgent
nutrition counseling I think they need
to hear I think we need I would start
with them I would start with
kindergarten nutrition with them this is
fake food not real food I would have to
teach them about about what real food is
all right yeah and it just is this
pretty this can someone say we just say
this is dangerous for oneself it's
certainly not not good nourishment
there's some of these products will give
the your body calories very poor quality
calories to work with but this is not
health supporting health sustaining
certainly never health building
nourishment and it's it's actually a
very tragically sad example of the lack
of nutritional consciousness in a major
medical industry known as a hospital if
if this is what they they think
nourishment is that goes to a very large
extent it helps to explain why it's
become so common in modern-day America
for almost everybody to have some type
of chronic health problem is there is
there a link between disease and these
type of foods of course of course there
is there's no question about it
the the very sad thing is that in a
hospital when people are in need of the
very best nutrition certainly the people
that are in the hospital those that are
visiting - I'm sure everybody visiting
would their bodies of not their taste
buds would appreciate real food and
better nutrition but the patient's
especially are in need of their very
best nutrition that God nature has to
offer not anything like this
I'm sure even the patients
free to come in here and indulge and
stuff and
no doctor
unless the doctor is uniquely
enlightened about the importance of
nutrition is going to discourage them
from partaking in this
the one thing about all these junk foods
one of the things that they all have in
common is that they all have addictive
qualities to them the addictive
qualities intentionally imparted into
them so that
a person will want to have it again and
again in some of these products have
really strong addictive qualities to
them
diet coke for instance they asked for
tame and the so called natural flavors
which until proven otherwise this is msg
in the caffeine and they're those three
very addictive inbreeding
inspire to produce some pretty strong
addictions and people I've worked with
over the years
I've known
worked with some people
they just could not break through diet
coke advantageous work
I
some diet coke
at some point in the course of the day
they would begin to experience very
serious withdrawal symptoms
very very unpleasant word
so
when you're eating real food and you're
avoiding fake food
when you begin to make that change
it's not unusual for people to go
through withdrawal symptoms
ingredients that are in
but we came in here because I you know I
saw the sign saying nourishment and I
wanted to see what they were
passing off his nourishment and it's
it's it's pathetic
it's sad and it's a betrayal of trust it
really is a betrayal of trust
advice for the people sitting in the
waiting room next time and they see this
type of nourishment
this type of
fake food that
that anybody eats any of the consumes I
mean that's all they're going to be
doing is feeding their addictions
feeding their addictions or you know
just quick fixing themselves at best
wouldn't it be wonderful if instead of
all of this they had they had a vending
machine with bananas or apples or maybe
he went some how about some they could
cups of organic yogurt
a small bottle of of quisiera
nuts a bag of organic almonds or walnuts
or sunflower seeds or pumpkin seeds
that's that's quick simple and easy
convenient real food
Thank You June